in the last video we named to some
fairly simple ethers in this video we're
going to think about slightly more
complicated ones and in particular what
happens if in the process of having an
ether we actually have a ring as opposed
to just a long chain so you could
imagine a molecule that looks something
like this you have your oxygen on this
side of the oxygen you have this carbon
chain right here you have a carbon chain
like this but then that chain bonds back
to the oxygen so we have a ring here and
so it's not obvious how to name this you
can't just look at this side and call it
you know methyl and then that side and
call it methyl as well it's the same
side it connects back to itself so how
do you name this type of ether so what
you do is you just number it you number
it you number the longest carbon chain
like we've always done in the case of an
alkane so this is we could start
numbering here 1 2 3 4 and so this if we
just think about the carbon chain by
itself we know if it's one carbon it's
the prefixes mat meth - its F 3 it's pro
4 it's Butte so if this was just a
carbon chain we would call this butane
so if we just looked if all we only
looked at this carbon chain right here
this carbon chain right there you would
call this butane you would call this
butane but obviously this isn't butane
we have this oxygen that's bonding to
the 1 and 4 carbons of the butane so to
make that clear we call this we call
this and let me color code this part
right here this oxygen right there it's
bonded to the 1 and the 4 carbon so we
call this 1 comma 4 and this is our new
word then we're going to learn in this
video 1 4 epoch C butane 1 4 epoxy
butane and it doesn't just apply when
the the ether forms a large ring it
could actually form a little subset ring
on a regular chain so you could imagine
something like this let me draw a chain
of carbons let's say we have five
carbons 1 2 3
or five just like that and then let's
say that between this carbon and this
carbon instead of having a double bond
this carbon actually bonds to an oxygen
which then bonds to this carbon over
here and obviously every carbon has four
bonds the ones that we're not drawing
those are hydrogen's how do we name this
well same exact process we start
numbering we actually start numbering
the chain closer to where the oxygen is
bonded so we start numbering at this end
over here 1 2 3 4 5 so this is pentane
this is pentane and then the oxygen is
bonded to the 1 and the 2 carbon so we
call this 1 2 epoxy pentane 1 comma 2
epoxy epoxy pentane now in the last
video I told you that in general ethers
are fairly nonreactive they actually
make for good solvents but what I've
just drawn here is a special case of
ethers called epoxide so when you just
have this kind of 3 3 atom chain right
here where it's two carbons in an oxygen
this is a special case of an ether
called an epoxide this is called an e
oxide and this
unlike most ethers is very reactive this
is very reactive or you could another
way you could think about it it's very
unstable this is very this is very
reactive so sometimes people kind of
consider these separate from ethers and
the reason why very reactive is this
kind of this 3 member ring right here is
there's a lot of strain on these bonds
these electrons these these bonds don't
like to be that close to each other if
you actually try to make it with an
actual model set with with molecules you
would have trouble making it Bend enough
to actually make this bond so this is
highly highly highly unstable and
there's actually an alternate way to
name Apoc sides the alternate way so
this is a completely legitimate way you
could name it just like an ether with a
ring this is 1/2 epoxy pentane
but the alternate way is to pretend like
you had a double bond here that the set
this oxygen here you had a double bond
if you had a double bond here this thing
this thing would be called this thing
would be called depending how you want
to name it you would you could be called
1-pentene 1-pentene that's if there was
not this oxygen here but if there was a
double bond here 1-pentene would look
like this 1 2 3 4 5 this is the 1 carbon
so 1 2 3 4 5 so this is what 1-pentene
looks like we've learned that many many
many videos ago sometimes it's called
pent 1 in depending on which convention
this is kind of the more common one but
we have this oxygen here instead of this
double bond we have this oxygen here
instead of this double bond so instead
of calling it just 1-pentene we call it
1-pentene oxide we call this one ten
teen 1-pentene oxide just like that so
both of these are this are the names for
the same exact molecule this makes it
clear that it's in the epoxide that's
kind of the special ether that is more
reactive this is just a general way that
we name any type of cyclic any type of
cyclic ether so let's just do one more
just to make the point clear let's have
a cycle branching off of a cycle let's
have an epoxide off of another another
ring just to make the point clear that
this these aren't too hard to name but
the first time you seem a little
daunting so let's say we have a
cyclohexane ring right here so let's say
we have a cyclohexane ring so leftward
so this is cyclohexane but let's say we
have a little epoxy branching off of it
just like this we have that going on so
if we wanted to make it clear that this
is an epoxide we would essentially
pretend what our first pretend that this
is just a double bond if this was just a
double bond this would be cyclohexene
this would be cyclohexene cyclo hexane
if this oxygen wasn't there instead we
just had a double bond here and you
actually don't have to specify the
number for just when you only have one
double bond in cyclohexene because it
could have been anywhere and it would
have essentially been the same molecule
but since we have this oxygen here
instead of a double bond that's bonding
to both of these
carbons we call this cyclohexene oxide
cyclohexene so this part right here
makes us name this cyclohexene oxide or
if we wanted to just name this as a
traditional as a traditional ether the
way we would do it we would just name
this we would just name this cyclohexane
cyclohexane cyclohexane and put the
epoxy in front of it and put the epoxy
epoxy either of these are valid and once
again you don't have to number it
because you know you could call it 1-2
epoxy cyclohexane if you made this the 1
or the 2 carbon but you know it's going
to be on on on on adjacent carbons and
it could have really been on any of
these 2 it could have been on the 3 and
the 4 and it essentially been the same
molecule so this actually makes it clear
exactly what the molecular structure of
the molecule is well anyway I thought
you would enjoy that in the next video
well I told you that epoch sides are
reactive so I'll actually show you a
reaction with that dealing with epoxides